بداية كلامي محتاج تعاونكم
وأدعو أيضًا الشرطة والفواتير لأخذها
شاركها كيف وصل الإجراء إلى ما نحن عليه
يجب عمله
الآن توقف لا زيادة تستمر
نعم، ارموا نتنياهو في سلة المهملات
التاريخ
نعم، تابع حتى النهاية
كشركة لم تكن قوية بما فيه الكفاية لذلك أسأل
توقف عن الاستمرار
نعم، ارموا نتنياهو في سلة المهملات
التاريخ لمواصلة
داشو 72% من الجمهور يؤيد
وفي منصب لمدة عام تمكن نتنياهو وحكومته من السحق
انت
الدولة، النظام القانوني، الاقتصاد
الشرطة، وزارة التربية والتعليم، العلاقات الخارجية مع
العالم المستنير بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
وخاصة المجتمع الإسرائيلي والثقة المدنية
الدولة في مؤسساتها
في عهد نتنياهو
وتمكنت حكومته من تنظيم حرب مسلحة بكيس اللكمات
شارع للدراجات النارية والشاحنات ذات المظلات
مزلق لتدمير معسكرات الجيش
ويعودون لقتل أكثر من 1200 مدني
وجنود يختطفون 240 مدنيا وجنديا
إلى الشريط
غزة حماس سخرت من الشر الإسرائيلي
وقدمت إسرائيل
[موسيقى]
في طولي